[Musique]
vous qui passez sans me
voir sans même dire bonsoir
donnez-moi un peu d'espoir ce soir
j'ai tant de
peine dont je guettete un
regard pour quelle raison ce soir
passez-vous sans me
voir une chans merveilleuse elle me fait
penser bien sûr puisque cette chanson a
était son indicatif elle est toujours du
reste à quelqu'un de non moins
merveilleux qui a vraiment versé toute
mon enfance toute mon adolescence je
peux le dire parce qu'il a quand même un
an ou de plus jusque moi Sacha Sacha il
est ici Jean Sablon oui Jean sablonc
voilà c'est le bonheur de vous de vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avoir
vous qui passez sans me
voir sans même me dire
bonsoir
donnez-moi un peu d'espoir ce
soir je tant de P
vous dont je guête un
regard pour quelle raison ce
soir
passez-vous sans me
voir un mot
oui je veux vous dire je vous
aime c'est ridicule c'est
beauèes c'est jeune et c'est
triste
aussi
vous qui passit sans me
voir sans me donner
d'espoir à
Dieu
[Musique]
bonsoir Merve merci beaucoup merci à
vous